early Avalanche for the Lakers
a 15-point lead under seven minutes in
we've got a foul call as Schroeder and
Draymond Green talking to each other
Courtney Kirkland and John and Global
and they're trying to decide a double
technical or just one
[Applause]
and to me that's the wrong call they get
true to what the technical foul Draymond
Green shoves them it should be a double
technical
how many technicals does green have
before he gets suspended for a game
though
in the three the floater instead he
passes it to Davis for the slam and a
turtle that can is played by the
Warriors Anthony Davis picks up the
steal after the dunk
and a technical bounce Rooter his second
technical he's ejected
man that just can't happen
your team's up 16. you have all the
momentum
and you get hit with your second
technical foul that's an automatic
ejection Darvin ham not happy with John
Goebel they're trying to say that
Draymond Green put the ball in
Schroeder's face
and he did
[Music]
wow why was Schroeder
why not a not not a double decker to a
shooter did something first that's a bad
call that's twice that it's been a
Schroeder Draymond Green and Schroeder
seemingly pretty innocuous